[Musique]
je suis dembaya terra je suis le
président du groupe sp société
spécialisée dans la sécurité privée
[Musique]
ma belle de christelle bonhomme je suis
professeur au lycée louis blériot à
trappes
j'enseigne au sein de la filière des
métiers de la sécurité
[Musique]
le partenariat avec le lycée
louis-blériot consiste dans un premier
temps de nous apporter des des
alternants le partenariat avec le groupe
sp nous permet de nous adosser au
savoir-faire d'une entreprise de pouvoir
les accompagner dans dans les métiers de
la sécurité leur apporter notre
savoir-faire notre expertise nous avons
beaucoup de stagiaires à peu près une
vingtaine depuis le début de l'année
nous avons également deux apprentis sur
le bac pro métiers de la sécurité et une
apprentie sur les bts management
opérationnel de la sécurité pour nous ça
nous permet vraiment de pouvoir prendre
ces personnes on va dire les formes et
comme on a envie de 2,2 de les former et
derrière ça ben pouvoir les embaucher
[Musique]
l intérêt qu trouve le lycée
louis-blériot partenariat avec la
société s p c'est de pouvoir mettre nos
élèves en situation réelle l'intérêt
dans ce partenariat c'est de pouvoir
prendre des jeunes et de pouvoir les
accompagner aider ces jeunes en fait
trouver une voie nos élèves ont une
partie théorique et pratique au lycée
mais ils les ont besoin également
d'avoir le côté factuelle de
l'entreprise donc l'expérience que peut
apporter spa nos élèves
l'expérience terrain est bénéfique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir
renforcer le partenariat avec avec le
lycée blériot développer nos contrats
d'apprentissage et nos stagiaires
également
[Musique]